auy Plaza's career is on fire now but a
medical setback nearly 20 years ago
threatened to end it before it ever
began in 2004 while she was a
20-year-old and a graduate at New York
University Aubrey Plaza suffered a
stroke that left her temporarily
paralyzed without the ability to speak
in a 2016 interview with the guardian
Plaza shared that she had suffered from
aasia a disorder which can severely
impact one's ability to communicate she
explained I had expressive a fasia where
I could understand what's happening but
I couldn't talk or communicate like you
could say something and I would know
what you meant but I couldn't express it
or even write it when they gave me a
piece of paper and a pen I just kept
writing lines instead of words every
time they asked me how old I was I would
go
16- which was the only number I could
say I don't know why Plaza added that
immediately after having the stroke
which happens when either blood is
prevented from getting to the brain or a
blood vessel within the brain itself
bursts she couldn't walk she record when
it first happened to me I was paralyzed
but I was so young that my brain healed
itself really fast I was really lucky in
that way maybe the most frightening part
of the entire ordeal as Plaza explained
to Fresh Air in 2017 is that because she
appeared okay when she got to the
emergency room she wasn't examined right
away however when she was her condition
was immediately apparent as she
remembered a doctor finally examined me
and I believe she asked me to put my
right hand on my left knee and I
couldn't do it I was confused about
right and left and I think that's when
everyone realized oh like she had a
stroke Plaza has been remarkably open
about what happened which is helpful to
other stroke victims who may be
reluctant to talk about their experience
for fear of being stigmatized Strokes
are in fact distressingly common as
Plaza told fresh air she was visiting a
friend at their apartment they were
discussing a Hillary Duff concert she'
attended with her sister when she
blacked out mid-sentence when she came
too she couldn't speak though her
friends thought she was joking at first
they eventually realized that it was
serious and called an ambulance Plaza
told fresh air there was no recovery I
mean when you have a stroke you have a
stroke there's nothing you can do about
it your brain has to heal itself Plaza
added that she still has lingering
complications from The Experience even
after cognitive therapy and a successful
recovery as she explained but I still
have things that only I would notice
that are kind of left over from that
incident and since then I've had some
minor they call them tias which are
transient isic attacks that are tiny
little strokes so something's up with my
blood but I don't know what it is just a
few years after her devastating medical
setback Plaza landed her career def
finding RA in 2009 she introduced the
world to suen intern April Ludgate on
the NBC sitcom Parks and Recreation
April lgate professional Drinker despite
a slow start the show hit it stride in
season 2 and Plaza's hilariously dead
pan April was a huge part of its success
alongside an All-Star cast that included
Amy po Chris Pratt Aziz Ansari Adam
Scott Rob low Rashida Jones Jim oare
Retta and Nick Offerman Plaza helped
make Parks and Recreation one of the
most beloved shows of the 2010s and
despite its consistently low ratings the
shows following and the love it got from
critics helped it run for a solid Seven
Seasons still the best was yet to come
for Plaza who didn't let her medical
situation keep her from her acting
Plaza's career remained healthy after
Parks and Recreation she appeared in
films like Mike and Dave need wedding
dates and ingred goes west as well as a
small screen series Legion and in 2022
she embarked on an entirely new creative
Journey with season 2 of Mike White's
hit Anthology series The White Lotus
White Lotus allowed the actor to flex
her muscles as a performer and
ultimately got attention from the
television Academy in the form of a
supporting actress Emmy nomination and
scary medical history or not Plaza shows
no signs of slowing down anytime
soon